well a ukrainian ban has received
permission to leave the country so they
can take part in the eurovision song
contest next month the musicians hope
the high-profile event will help them
draw attention to the devastating war
back home
for ukrainian ban kaloush orchestra it's
a very special concert the musicians
have taken to the stage for the first
time since war broke out
in tel aviv they play the song with
which they hope to win the upcoming
eurovision song contest
[Music]
but for the band members this is about
more than just eurovision
they want to use the concert to raise
funds for ukrainian refugees
while traveling in israel the musicians
worry about what's happening back home
during a stroll through jerusalem's old
city they spread the news about the
situation there
[Music]
i'm happy to be able to help ukrainians
these activities are another chance for
us to be a mouthpiece to remind people
everywhere about the situation there
that's really important these days
the musicians had to get special
permission to travel to israel in the
first place
all males of fighting age are barred
from leaving ukraine but there are
exceptions now the troop has been
allowed to travel as representatives of
their country
expectations of them are high and the
war has made preparing for eurovision
even harder
we all live in different towns
throughout ukraine
and we didn't have a chance to rehearse
in person
instead we practice online
[Music]
is the name of the song that kaloush
orchestra will perform at the eurovision
song contest
they had originally dedicated it to
their mothers but now they say they want
it to become an anthem for ukraine
according to bookmakers they're the
favorites to win
[Music]
you